le nouveau projet de loi sur
l'enseignement supérieur adopté en
conseil des ministres aujourd'hui un
conseil décidément très chargé c'est un
texte qui renforce l'autonomie des
universités et le rôle des professeurs
explications et réactions
estelle ouzou côté étudiants le bac sert
toujours de passeport pour entrer dans
l'enseignement supérieur mais les
universités obtiennent le droit d'exiger
ouvertement d'autres critères par
exemple une mention au bac ou de bons
résultats dans certaines disciplines
le montant des droits d'inscription sera
désormais laissée à l'appréciation des
universités mais dans des limites fixées
par le ministre les diplômes nationaux
sont maintenues mais en plus chaque
université pourra créer le sien et
demandé à l'état un label de
reconnaissance
c'est sur ces trois points que le projet
est le plus vivement critiqué par
l'opposition
sous couvert d'autonomie entre les
universités il instaure la sélection ce
qui va se traduire par des université à
deux vitesses
et qu'est-ce qui va se traduire par des
universités qui seront pour certaines
des pôles d'excellence notamment à paris
dans certaines villes provinciales
mais pour d'autre part des universités
de second ordre côté universités les
structures change les universités les
plus importantes seront divisés en
établissement autonome on revient tout
simplement aux facultés d'avant 68 dans
les conseils chargés de veiller à la
qualité des enseignements
les professeurs retrouve une place
prépondérante les universités deviennent
donc plus autonome
mais cette autonomie à ses limites le
budget et l'attribution des postes
d'enseignants reste entièrement sous
contrôle de l'état
pourtant favorable à une réforme plus
libérale certains membres de la majorité
soutiendront quand même ce projet je
serais probablement aller un peu plus
loin que le projet de loi en fait
d'autonomie des universités belges ou
concierges ce projet de voie réalise
déjà d'importants progrès et que
quelquefois le mieux est l'ennemi du
bien et que l'essentiel c'est que nous
adoptions ce projet compte tenu du
programme chargé de la session
extraordinaire ce projet de loi ne
devrait pas être discutée à l'assemblée
nationale avant l'automne